[Müzik]
Merhaba ben Nalan Kanatoğlu Öncelikle
bana bu fırsatı verdiğiniz için
çok teşekkür ederim
size bugünkü kayıp konusunda bir iki
tercih kendimle yaşamış oldum açıkçası
gerçekten şu an çok heyecanlıyım yani
açıldıkça konuk şey konuşmam açıldıkça
heyecanım atmış olacağım Biraz daha
Kusura bakmayın biraz da rahatsızım
geçen haftanın ve sesin açıkçası şey
çıkmıyor Çok
net kırılgan çıkıyor Şu anda Onun da
şeyi var Birazcık heyecanı var
bugünkü kayıp konusunda sizlere kendi
yaşamış olduğunu gerçek hikaye üzerine
bir anlatım yapmak isteyeceğim yapmaya
çalışacağım
yaşamış olduğum hikaye şöyle; şimdi
hepimiz biliyoruz ki insanın
insanda olmadan önce
annesi ve babası tarafından büyük bir
heyecanla DC arayışına girmektedir ve
isim
doğar doğmaz da bu isimle çağrılmakta
Ancak şöyle bir durum oluyor insan ismi
ile birlikte çağrılıyor ve insanın kendi
kültürel
kendi
karakterinin oluşmasının sebep olan
karakterin oluşmasına yardımcı olan
bir gün geliyor ve zorla insanın elinden
alınması alınıyor ve bu da insanlık
içerisinde
isminin alınması insana büyük bir kayıp
a sebep oluyor bu da insanın kendinin
benliğini karakterini hatta her şey
aslında kaybetmesine sebep oluyor Şimdi
bu yaşanan
sosyoektik sosyo kültürel hayvan Aslında
deniyor Aslında
nasıl asimilasyon terimi kelime anlamı
olarak nedir
eminim İçimizden hepiniz biliyorsunuzdur
Az önce Arif hocamın anlatmış olduğu
konu mübadeleydi benim konumda
simülasyon konusu ve asimilasyon
sonrasında yaşanan zorunlu göç zorunlu
göç ve gerçekten hiç birbirimizden
birbirimizden şeyimiz yokken haberimiz
yokken çok birbirini örtüşen konular peş
peşe gelmiş
asimilasyon aslında bir kültürün bir
başka kültür tarafından bir ya da bir
medeniyet tarafından bir ülke tarafından
zorunlu olarak onun din değil ırk
ve hatta
düşünce kültürel düşüncelerine kadar
sahip olduğu düşünce kültürellerini
hepsini alınmasını ve zorunlu olarak
diğer güç olan yani
güçlü olan ülkenin
şeyin altına girmesi boyundurun altına
girmesiydi fakat şöyle bir şey olmuştu
benim yaşadığım Topraklar
Bulgaristan'dan orada doğdum büyüdüm
yaşamış olduğum Topraklar Bulgaristan
toprakları
Siz 500 yıl boyunca Osmanlı toprakların
Osmanlı Hükümdarlığı altında bulunmuş ve
bu dönemde Osmanlı hiçbir şekilde Orada
bulunan azınlık olarak bulunan tüm
hiçbir topluluğa
herhangi bir asimilasyon uygulamış Yani
herkes çok rahat bir şekilde kendi
kültürünü kendi dilini dilini
rahatlıkla yaşamaya fırsatı vermiştir
ancak Osmanlı'da çekildikten sonra
Bulgaristan kendi tam bağımsızlığını
1908 yılında ilan ediyor ve
tam olarak Osmanlı Bulgaristan
topraklarından çekildikten sonra o
dönemde azınlık olarak bazı küçükler
yaşamaya devam ediyor
devam eden devam eden orada yaşamaya
devam eden Türklerin içerisinde Benim
ailemin de ailemden kalanlar da olmuş
Tabii felç ben değil ürün gibi birçok
Türkler olmuş ve dönem
1980'li yıllara gelindiğinde yaklaşık
olarak Bulgaristan'da yaşayan Türklerin
Bulgar toprağı Bulgaristan
topluluğun yani nüfusun %20'sini
içermekte Bu da açıkçası Bulgar hükümeti
için Bulgaristan hükümeti için bir nedir
bir tehdit oluşturmaya başlamış neden
tehdit Çünkü biliyorsunuz ne zaman
azınlık olarak azınlık aslında hiçbir
şekilde
hükümetin şeylerini politikalarına
teklif etmeyecek şekilde olması
gerekiyor ama belli bir oranı aştığı
zaman artık hükümetin her türlü
her türlü politikasını
[Müzik]
kendi tehditini azaltmaya azaltabilmek
için bunun için de zaten zaman
içerisinde
Bulgaristan'da dönemde içerisinde
Bulgaristan'da hep bir asimilasyon
uygulanmış dönem dönem uygulanmış ilk
uygulanan simülasyon
pomatlara uygulanmıştır bunların adını
Türkler Türk nüfusu kadar olmadığı için
onlar çok çok daha az olduklarından
dolayı bunları uygulanan asimilasyon
asimilasyon politikası çok ses
getirmemiş bunu şey olarak bunu örnek
olarak gören Bulgaristan hükümeti
düşünmüş ki artık tek bulgur tek millet
şeklinde olmamız gerekiyor Bunun için de
Türklerin de kalan en son kalan azalının
türklerinde bir şekilde bunları da
buharlaştırmamız gerekiyor Bu düşünce
ilk defa 1956 yılında
seslendiren sesli olarak daha önce
düşünce olarak düşündükleri Fikri daha
sonra seslendirmeye başlamışlar Bu
politika içerisinde kültürel
Devrim olarak kadınlardaki başörtüsü
çıkarmaya yönelik
işte bazı
mesela erkek çocuklarındaki sünneti
yasaklamışlar Ondan sonra Ordu Ve Kamu
dairelerinde Kamu dairelerinde Türklerin
çalışmasını engellemişler
Türkleri daha çok o dönemde o
topraklarda daha çok Tarım Hayvancılık
işte
Ondan sonra
karayollarının yapımında tren yollarının
yapımında Yani açıkçası çok daha böyle
ağır işlerde kullanılmış Türk nüfusu
destan
daki
1984'e gelindiğinde
artık Bulgaristan hükümet böyle bir
karar almıştır ki bu kararı alırken tek
başına almıyor Bu kararı alırken o
dönemki büyük Rusya'nın desteği ile
alıyor
bu kararının Rusya'nın da şöyle bir
düşüncesi varmış o dönemde
kendisinin içerisinde de biliyorsunuz
Yani daha sonra 1989'dan sonra
peresteroleka olduktan sonra Türk Rusya
büyük Rusya Devleti bölündükten sonra
birçok Türkiye Cumhuriyetler çıktı
işin Onun amacı şuydu önce Küçük çapta
bir deneme yapıp hani
[Müzik]
en son yapmaya çalıştıkları adım ve bunu
1984 yılında gerçekleştirmeye çalıştılar
yani isim asimilasyonu isim değiştirmek
ne demek yani Türkçenin doğduğun
büyüdüğün Türk ismini alıp sana zorlu
bir şekilde zoraki bir şekilde Bulgarca
sen artık atıyorum Bu yaşa kadar yaşamış
olduğun Belki 40 Belki 50 belki 60-7
sene yaşamış olduğunu ve sana herkesin
etrafında seslenmiş olduğu bir Türk
ismiyle artık sana bundan sonrası herkes
seni bir Bulgaristan ile seslenmeye
başlıyor ve kayıtlar resmi kayıtlarda
kayıtların Hatta kimliklerin her şeyin
Türkçesi her şeyden Türk hissesinin
siliniyor ve bulgarsini yerine
getiriliyor
İşte bunun için 1984 yılında
bu isim değiştirme asimilasyonuna
başladı Bulgaristan hükümeti ve
2-3 ay içerisinde tüm Bulgaristan
topraklarında yaşayan yaklaşık olarak
dediğim gibi %20'sini oluşturan
Türklerin Bu da yaklaşık bir buçuk
milyondan fazla Türkün olduğu anlamına
gelmektedir yani o dönem için
19880 yılları
bulgarlaştırılması tam anlamıyla
bulgarlaştırması
başlandı ve 3 ay içerisinde bu
tamamlandı ama bu 3 ay içerisinde
tamamlama sürecinde
Türklerin oradaki yaşadıkları baskılar
aşağılamalar
Yani
aklınıza gelebilecek her türlü
baskıyı gördük
Açıkçası ben bizzat kendim yaşadım o
dönemde Ben 8-9 yaşlarında bir
öğrenciydi çocuktum ve
ismimin değişmemesinden dolayı yani
ismimi değiştirmediğimden dolayı ben
Okulu alamadım
ben annem İşe gitmedi işe gidemedi işe
alınmadı Neden Çünkü Türk ismiyle git
tiği için bunu nasıl gerçekleştirdiler
bunu gerçekleştirme aşamasında Öncelikle
Türk şey Bulgar hükümetine karşı
gelebilecek Yani bu yürütülen bu
işlemlere karşı gelebilecek tüm
[Müzik]
erkekler Yani biraz daha böyle
öncülük yapabilecek erkeklerin hepsine
önceden
Ala konuldular Yani nasıl zoraki bir
şekilde
bir tarafından gelip baskınla ya evinde
ya içinde baskınla alıp ana konuldu tüm
erkekler ve bir bir buçuk ay boyunca
Ala konuldukları yerlerden hiçbir
şekilde ailelerine haber verilmedi o
dönemde Ben çok iyi hatırlıyorum
annem babama şey götürmüşler o dönemde
Benim babam da alıp konuldu Annem babamı
giyecek Çünkü iş yerini ana konuldu ve
üst baş yani
bir kıyafetlerle oraya gittik Annem de
bir ona bir küçük bir valiz hazırlamıştı
ve bir karakoluna gittik böyle böyle bir
kişi sizin şeyle duruyor yatıyor mu
Mesela bende kalıyor mu dediler ki bize
çok iyi hatırlıyorum dediler ki
Biz Öncelikle çantayı kontrol edeceğiz
çantayı kontrol ettikten sonra size
çantanın içerisinde Zaten iç çamaşırı ve
birkaç tane pijamadan ibaret
bir şey vardı içerik vardı kontrol
ettiler ve de çantayı aldılar bizden ve
şunu dediler Biz de bu bilgiyi veremeyiz
Neyse bu şekilde aldılar götürdüler
ondan sonra
tabii biz babamdan yaklaşık olarak işte
kaldığı süre kadar bir buçuk ay bir iki
buçuk bir süre boyunca Biz babamla
hiçbir şekilde içerde o yani içeride
sağımız sağın Yaşıyor mu yoksa sağlık
durumu ne durumda olduğunu konusunda
hiçbir şekilde haber alamadık
ve nihayetinde bütün bu
işlemlerden sonra artık zaten Türklerin
kaçacağı hiçbir yer yoktu tamamen
sıkışmışlardı erkekler yok etrafta karşı
koyabilecek bir kuvvetin yok elinde
hiçbir buna karşı koyabilecek hiçbir
şeyim yok En sonunda ne oldu Herkes
mecburen gidip ismini değiştirmek
zorunda kaldı ve ondan sonra biz Ondan
sonra zaten yaklaşık olarak bir 4-5 sene
sonra
4-5 sene boyunca biz bu isimlerle Orada
yaşamak durumda kaldık bu isimlerle
okulda çağrıldı bu isimlerle sınavlara
girdik bu isimlerle her şeyimiz bu
isimlerle Hazırlandı Nitekim
artık bir tekim hepiniz Naim
süleymanoğlu'nu biliyorsunuzdur
[Müzik]
bu ateşin fitilini başlatan kişi ilk
saat ilk
1986 ya da 87 yılında Seo
olimpiyatlarında Türkiye hükümetin ona
filmleri izledin zaten bütün hikayeyi
Türkiye hükümeti buna destek çıkması ve
yani orada Olimpiyatlar esnasında
kaçıyor ve Türkiye'ye sığınıyor ve
Türkiye adına katılmış oldu
Bulgar Bulgaristan adına gitti fakat
sonunda Türk vatandaşı olarak Türk o
olimpiyatlara
katıldı ve ondan sonra zaten kendini
Ondan sonra aynı Süleymanoğlu ses
getirdi bütün dünya bunu dinlediği
yapılan bütün
zürrilere bütün güç gösterimlere Yani
bütün insan baskılarını yaşanan bütün
baskıları anlattı televizyonlarda işte
başka başka devletlerin söyleşilerinde
vesaire anlattı ve artık Bulgaristan
buna karşı koyamadın ve 1980 Yani bütün
bu
ülkeye baskılarının karşı koyamadı ve
1989 yılında
Bulgaristan şunu dedi şunu yaptı
yine bu bir önceki İsim değişikliğinde
erkeklerin hepsini tekrar topladım
topladı ve bunları bir Haziran 1989
yılında pasaportların hazırladı ve
bunlara dedi ki sadece 2 saatlik bir
süresi var rengi sadece içerisinden
Ülkeyi terk etmeniz gerekiyor
ve hepsini toplayıp
Türk Bulgar sınırına getirdi ve onları
oradan gönderdim zoraki bir şekilde
düşünün ki şu anda kendi düşün mesela
zorla aldığınız götürdünüz başka bir
ülke elinizde hiçbir şey yok ne
yapabilirsiniz
gerçekten çok zor bir yaşam
ve onlar bu şekilde geldiler ardından da
onların ailelerinin aynısı olarak aynı
zorlama yapıldı
Biz de ben de annem ve kız kardeşim biz
de bu şekilde
buraya buraya geldikten sonra tabii
bize hani Türkçe
dil bir şey hazırda değildi
Bizim için her şey çok her şey Yani
bütün zorluklar devam etmeye başladı Ama
tek
olan tarafı artık vatanımızı da yıkadık
Tek iyi tarafı artık biz kendimizi Türk
olarak hissettiğimiz topraklarda
yaşıyorduk
bize Bulgaristan'da bizim Türk olarak
bizi bizim Türklerin Türk olarak
hissettirmiyorlardı yani bizi
aşağılanmış bir topluluk
uluk ve Bu da gerçekten çok acı bir şey
yani bir
Senin kendi kimliğini kendi varlığını
hissetmeden Yaşamak bir sığıntı gibi
düşünün kendinizi bir sıkıntısınız ve
sıkıntı olarak yaşıyorsunuz
Yani duygusal olarak kendini tatmin
edemiyorsun hiçbir
şey Evet nihayetinde 1989'da buraya
geldiğimizde Artık biz bir Türk
gerçekten bir Türk ve
her tarafımızda hissettiğiniz bir
türklüğümüz vardı
ama nihayetinde hepimiz bu zorlukları
aşmayı başardık nasıl vatan sevgisi
çalışma arzusuyla bütün burada o dönemde
gelen
lerin hele Türkiye'nin
Türkiye Türkiye tutulup sarılıp bunu
yaşamaya başladık
açıkçası
şunu size söylemek istiyorum Bir siz
daha çok gençsiniz hepiniz 15 16 17 18
yaşında gençlersiniz en önemlisi insanın
vatanın vatanın
vatanını
sahiplenip o vatan için çalışmak bu
dünyadaki en önemli şeylerden bir tanesi
Çünkü vatanın Eğer vatanını Kaybedersen
Ben her şeyini kaybetmiş oluyorsun
[Alkış]